when you're talking about the best you
are you you might actually be hurting
someone because you know let's say that
oh I go to the went to this restaurant
it's 500 bucks a plate and you know
Mariah and I did it on our anniversary
or something and it was just one
once-in-a-lifetime thing and I'm telling
you know someone about oh man this the
best restaurant in the world is this
restaurant it's 500 bucks a plate now
you're giving someone the fear of
missing out right like I think that's
one place where I am more frugal than a
lot of people is with food because it's
such a because often the money does not
equal quality yeah I've learned that
unfortunately the hard way in LA the
Uppal times yeah and you can get really
good quality at Chipotle yep and you can
go spend four times as much and get a
mediocre meal yeah that's good
I also think I have this aversion to
being waited on I hate being waited on
and so like if I have to go somewhere
where they come to your table to take
your order mmm it really turns me on
it's uncomfortable man because it's like
when you have when you have that
experience with a waiter it's like this
I I always go out of my way to say hey
thanks for doing what you do like I
can't I wouldn't be able to enjoy this
nice meal and I won't be able to have
this experience if it wasn't for you but
I don't think that's why I don't like
the I could still have I actually think
I'd have a better experience if that
person wasn't there and that's why it's
a problem I had because then it
manufactures this sort of faux dialogue
for me like okay I have to interact with
this first
that's what I'm getting at is like there
is this faux dialogue that goes on
because you're trying to show
appreciation and not in you know you're
trying to mean for me it's I'm trying
not to be pretentious like look at me
I'm being waited on yeah that's why like
when I see people being mean to waiters
like I was I was in Chicago
Mariah's sister was bartending at this
really really nice restaurant so we sat
at the bar she fed us some really good
food really good
pairings but then there's this like this
table and the this they're treating the
waiter like crap like it's horrible and
I want to be like what in what world are
you entitled to treat anyone like that
because you're spending money and it's
funny because that's actually what this
article kind of helped me realize too is
like we unfortunately have this
expectation that if we have enough money
we can buy the best product or we can
buy the best experience or we could
whatever it is and then that's our
expectation and then the experience
happens or we get the product and then
it doesn't give us that elation that we
were expecting it's all marketing so
yeah so it's not it and the only reason
like the dude at the table who was going
off on the waiter for whatever reason
like that's his own insecurities his own
disappointment his I mean that's on him
and has nothing to do with the
restaurant the food was amazing like it
had nothing to do with the food it had
everything to do with this dude set it
up in his head that if he spent a
certain amount of money that he's
entitled to X Y & Z and instead he only
got X & Y so now there's this like
unsettling discontent but the same thing
happens with products like I mean I I
haven't gone through I try to think of
something when I was reading this I was
actually trying to think of something
that that's happened with me but there
certainly are products that I have gone
out on my way to to buy and finally get
it and then it's a piece of junk right
or even if it's not but it doesn't live
up to the thing that was promised the
the seductive marketing branding message
of of this you know maybe you're not
even discontented with the product that
you have but you just stop using it or
you you set it aside somewhere and and
it just collects dust in a cabinet or
attic somewhere that creates a different
kind of discontent it's a built-up
discontent because you if you do this
over and over and over and over with
thousands of items you just your homes
become a storage locker of things that
are creating discontent in your life
this makes me think of the Axe body
spray it's like they sell this certain
image I mean I can't tell you the last
time I've seen one of those commercials
but like yeah though where the dude like
sprays all over his body and like women
are falling for them and then it's like
I mean that's a that's a lifestyle that
they're trying to sell but buying Beck's
body spray it's not if anything it's the
opposite my former spouse to eighth
grade teacher yeah and she's like her
classrooms smell like perfume ball sweat
and Axe body spray because a lot of
eighth graders instead of showering they
just spray extra Axe body spray oh you
read that article about the dude who
never washed his hands
no anyway well senator shining put a
link in the notes okay I'm gonna wrap up
this article here cuz it's a long one
but ultimately she realizes that all of
these things were really stressing her
out but I think the thing that was
stressing her out more is her lifestyle
she goes through this whole article and
she's like staying out and eating pizzas
she she's making bad decisions and the
products themselves are not going to
cover up bad decisions that is tweetable
just ness if you're listening to this
you